sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder den des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gerollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und schiffe nicht gefahren
[Musik]
im krieg geht es um menschen
mit
oder ohne uniform
[Musik]
menschen in städten
dörfern
welt an
verbündete fremde
[Musik]
verfeindeten nachbarn
hunderte millionen menschen
die sechs jahre und einen tag lang
die hölle auf erde durchlebten
[Musik]
die deutschen truppen haben europa
überrannt und großbritannien ist
isoliert die schweiz irland portugal
schweden und die türkei sind neutral
spaniens sympathisiert der rest des
kontinents ist besetzt oder verbündet
in hitlers neu machtbereich leben mehr
menschen als in den usa
der diktator richtet sein augenmerk nun
auf die sowjetunion denn er will für die
arischen herrenrasse wie er es nennt
lebensraum im osten erobern um das zu
erreichen plant hitler einen
vernichtungskrieg
[Musik]
zwischen januar und juni 1941
transportieren 17.000 züge rund drei
millionen deutsche soldaten in richtung
osten
darunter 3000 ss männer die bei einem
vormarsch der wehrmacht völkische
flurbereinigung durchführen sollen denn
heinrich himmler reichsführer ss hat den
auftrag mit seinen einheiten die
physische vernichtung des wittler es
nennt jüdisch bolschewistischen
untermenschen teams zu realisieren
[Musik]
am 31 januar sagt hitler zu seinen
generälen im hinblick auf die
sowjetunion
ich bin überzeugt dass unser angriff wie
ein hagelsturm über sie hinweggeht
[Musik]
er ist in seinem zweiten buch schrieb
hitler voller neid über den
vernichtungsfeldzug der amerikaner gegen
die ureinwohner nordamerikas
dirk war betrachtete die ukraine als
brodkorb der weizen fleisch und milch
liefern sollte
[Musik]
am 30 märz spricht hitler vor 250
offizieren general alfred jodl notiert
der bevorstehende kampf ist ein kampf
zweier weltanschauungen die jüdisch
bolschewistische intelligenz muss
beseitigt werden
der überfall auf die sowjetunion war ein
konventioneller und ein ideologischer
krieg zugleich
doris frank es gab keinerlei
zurückhaltung
es war ein rassen ideologischer krieg
auch general franz falter notiert am
dreißigsten märz hitlers worte
es handelt sich um einen
vernichtungskraft wir führen nicht krieg
um den feind zu konservieren
nach dem krieg stufen deutsche generäle
den britischer oder amerikanischer
gefangenschaft waren den mythos einer
sauberen wehrmacht dass herr sanieren
diesen verbrechen beteiligt gewesen
die wahrheit aber ist dass die wehrmacht
diese befehle von anfang an mit
ausgeführt hat
einer dieser befehle ist der sogenannte
kommissar befehl darin steht kommissare
werden nicht als soldaten anerkannt der
für kriegsgefangene völkerrechtlich
geltende schutz findet keine anwendung
[Musik]
hitler hielt die kommissare für die
treibende kraft für die ideologischen
zellen der roten armee
mario sie sollten sofort getötet werden
generalfeldmarschall wilhelm keitel
unterzeichnet das dokument in dem über
die behandlung der kommissare steht
sie sind nach durchgeführte absonderung
zu erledigen
[Musik]
sie nannten sich vorboten eines neuen
europas die waren in wirklichkeit aber
verbrecher die das sowjetische volk
bekämpften ganze dörfer nieder brannten
und frauen und kinder töteten
[Musik]
generalfeldmarschall weiter von
brauchitsch meldet hitler seiner
allgemeinen überlegungen
aufmarsch dauert vier bis sechs wochen
erwünscht so weit vorzudringen dass man
mit unserer luftwaffe wichtigste gebiete
russlands zerschlagen kann
im protokoll der besprechung der
staatssekretäre vom 2 mai steht der
krieg ist nur weiter zu schieben wo die
gesamte wehrmacht aus russland in die
türkei hierbei werden 50 millionen
menschen verloren
diese erwartung findet sich auch in den
so genannten
wirtschaftspolitischen richtlinien der
gruppe landwirtschaft vom 23 mai wieder
viele menschen werden in diesem gebiet
überflüssig und werden sterben oder nach
sibirien auswandern müssen
recording der generalplan ost sei für
das weißrussische territorium vor dass
nur 25 prozent der bevölkerung da
bleiben können
um
1 75 prozent sollten getötet oder
umgesiedelt werden
[Musik]
in lugano wie im generalplan ost stand
auch geschrieben es sei zu teuer ältere
slawische menschen zu töten
[Musik]
einige von ihnen würden noch gebraucht
die anderen sollten verhungern aus alles
sehr praktisch gedacht
sie planten eiskalt millionen von
menschen zu ermorden dennoch viele
millionen mehr als durch den holocaust
fonds 6 millionen waren 69 hunger plan
gingen sie von 30 millionen menschen
[Musik]
am 11 juni warnt ein sowjetischer agent
stalin vor dem bevorstehenden angriff
der deutschen
der diktator weiß diesen hinweis wie
auch andere vehement zurück
je mehr von britischer seite über die
deutschen vorbereitungen erfuhr desto
mehr war davon überzeugt dass es sich um
einen komplett handelte er glaubte die
briten wollten ihn aus eigenem interesse
in einen krieg mit hitler treiben
[Musik]
während stalin noch auf den
nichtangriffspakt mit hitler vertraut
laufen im deutschen reich die
kriegsvorbereitungen auf hochtouren
hitler will mit dem überfall auf die
sowjetunion auch england die wie er es
nennt letzte hoffnung auf einen festland
stegen nehmen nämlich stalin auf dem
europäischen festland als alliierten
gegen deutschland gewinnen zu können
so muss so linie sagt er ich fühle mich
seit ich mich zu diesem entschluss
durchgerungen habe innerlich wieder frei
das codewort dortmund gilt als
startsignal für das unternehmen
barbarossa am
22 juni gegen 3.15 morgens überfällt das
deutsche reich die sowjetunion ohne
kriegserklärung und mit der größten
invasionsarmee die bis dahin je zusammen
gezogen wurde ein soldat aus einer der
166 einfallenden divisionen erinnert
sich wir marschierten in russland ein
man hatte uns gesagt dass die russen
zuerst angegriffen hätten also zogen wir
los um ihnen eine lektion zu erteilen
stalin hat in den drei monaten zuvor
über 80 warnungen vor einem angriff und
180 verletzungen des sowjetischen
luftraums ignoriert
nun funkt ein sowjetischer außenposten
wir werden geschossen was sollen wir tun
mit der bekannten panzer taktik die man
zuvor versagt hat machte sich nach
deutschland an die sowjets zu
überwältigen und hitler noch vor ende
des sommers einen vollständigen
einmarsch in moskau zu ermöglichen
den teilnehmern die deutschen
streitkräfte einschließlich ihre
verbündeten rumänien finnland und andere
nationen kamen auf knapp vier millionen
an die die sowjetische grenze überqueren
und losschlagen sollten
[Musik]
deutsche bomber greifen 66 sowjetische
flugplätze an und zerstören mehr als
1200 sowjetische flugzeuge am boden
stellte werden bombardiert juli
kuznetsov soldat in der roten armee
erinnert sich wir erwarten vom lärm auf
der vom himmel kam da flogen flugzeuge
im sturzflug auf uns zu wir dachten es
sei eine übung aber es waren die
deutschen
[Musik]
die in welchem version vorliegt anfang
sehr erfolgreich für die deutschen die
zerstörten große teile der sowjetischen
luftwaffe bevor deren flugzeuge
überhaupt los fliegen konnten
als general schukoff im kreml anruft
wird ihm gesagt stalin schlafe noch
wecken sie ihn umgehend auf die
deutschen bombardieren unsere städte
[Musik]
bei einbruch der dunkelheit am 22 juni
erklären italien und rumänien der
sowjetunion den krieg finnland schließt
sich am 25
ungarn am 27 juni
die deutsche armee im osten wird zudem
von niederländischen französischen
dänischen kroatischen slowakischen
ungarischen rumänischen und spanischen
freiwilligen unterstützt die
heeresgruppe nord mitte und süd machen
sich auf den weg zu ihren zielen die
gruppe nord soll leningrad einnehmen die
gruppe süd kiew die gruppe mitte hat als
größte formation so viele panzer wie die
anderen beiden zusammen sie soll
smolensk erobern
sie fuhren einfach drauf los das war ein
echtes problem denn es fehlte die
unterstützung durch die infanterie es
gelang ihnen zwar minsk einzukesseln und
gut 300.000 sowjetische kriegsgefangene
zu machen aber der großteil der
deutschen infanterie kam viel zu langsam
hinterher
am 23 juni notierte goebbels in sein
tagebuch
wir werden es bald schaffen wir müssen
es auch bald schaffen im volk ist eine
leicht deprimierte stimmung
[Musik]
in einigen teilen der ukraine und des
baltikums begrüßen manche einwohner die
invasoren sogar als befreier
denn dortige bestrebungen nach
nationaler unabhängigkeit waren infolge
des hitler stalin pakts brutal
zerschlagen worden
aber den deutschen geht es nicht um
befreiung sondern um unterwerfung und
vernichtung auch hermann göring rechnet
mit 20 bis 30 millionen toten allein
durch hunger und fügt hinzu
und vielleicht ist das gut so denn
gewisse völker müssen dezimiert werden
damit ihre abscheulichen politik
brachten die deutschen ende 1941 die
bevölkerung gegen sich auf
einer der hauptfaktoren der zu ihrer
niederlage beigetragen hat
am 24 juni beginnt das einsatzkommando
tilsit mit der erschießung von 200
männlichen juden vor ort und 201 juden
in garstadt tags drauf ermordet iss
einsatzgruppe 214 juden in kritiker am
27 juni 111 in palanga und zwischen dem
vierter und sechster juli rund 30.000
juden im litauischen kaunas
die holocaust der holocaust beginnt
nicht den auschwitz oder in einem lager
er beginnt auf den schlachtfeldern der
besetzten sowjetunion
nur drei tage nach der invasion kann die
luftwaffe die angriffe reduzieren und
mit dem bau taktischer stützpunkte
beginnen
die rote armee verliert 1941
21.200 ihrer
32.000 100 flugzeuge und zwei drittel
auf den iq coachen liegt nahe der grenze
in der nähe meines dorfes begannen die
vorbereitungen für den bau eines reserve
flughafens alle kolchosen erhielten
befehl menschen und pferde zur verfügung
zu stellen so mussten wir den bau des
zukünftigen flughafens unterstützen
am tag nach der invasion hatte stalin
den großen vaterländischen krieg des
sowjetischen volkes ausgerufen drei tage
später am 26 juni muss erich von
manstein spencer chor an der westlichen
wiener anhalten und warten
es war eine moderne armee panzer
motorisierte infanterie sie stießen vor
zerstörten und durchbrachen die
sowjetischen linien zu 80 prozent war
das immer noch eine marschieren der
infanterie wie zu napoleons zeiten
am 27 juni begeht das der 221 infanterie
division unterstellte polizei bataillon
309 india rostock ein furchtbares
massaker mit über 2.000 jüdischen opfern
über 700 von ihnen verbrennen in einer
synagoge die deutschen angezündet haben
einen tag später kapituliert die stadt
minsk
als heinrich himmler war woodstock
anfang juli besucht sagt er zu ss und
polizeioffizieren das in seinen augen
jeder partie sahne ein jude sei ein
willkommener vorwand zu mehr morgen
schon eine woche nach beginn des
überfalls hat die vorhut der deutschen
truppen fast ein drittel des weges nach
moskau zurück gelegt aber die siebte
panzerdivision die den vorstoß der
heeresgruppe mitte anführt meldet den
verlust von 50 prozent der panzer
kampfwagen zwei und drei und von 75
prozent der panzer kampfwagen 4
hauptsächlich wegen technischen
versagens
die panzer und lastwagen wirbelten
unterwegs eine menge staub auf er
gelangte in die luftfilter luftfilter
der 30er 40er jahre und damit quasi
direkt in die motoren
[Musik]
die erste partisanen schlacht des
krieges findet am 28 juni bei pinske
statt
der sichere weg durch die sümpfe war
sehr schmal wenn ein deutscher konvoi
den morast durchquerte mussten die
partisanen im grunde nur den ersten und
den letzten wagen ausschalten denn dann
saßen die deutschen fest und wenn sie
aus ihren fahrzeugen sprangen starben
sie im sumpf
[Musik]
in den besetzten gebieten organisieren
sich immer mehr zivilisten und geflohene
rotarmisten um den vormarsch der
deutschen zu stoppen hitler erklärt
eiserner grundsatz muss sein und bleiben
nie darf erlaubt werden dass ein anderer
waffen trägt als der deutsche
einige games partys vor wie die
deutschen handeln nach der devise wenn
wir ein oder zwei gewehre im dorf finden
muss es ein partisanen dorf sein dann
brennen wir alles nieder und bringen
alle um
in weißrussland wurden auf diese weise
mehr als eine million nicht jüdische
einwohner getötet
in der fürst in dem ersten kriegswinter
gab es mehrere hunderttausend kinder die
jünger als ein jahr waren
wärmer das ihre mütter hatten keine
milch und es gab auch keinen ersatz
dafür
für sie war es unmöglich zu überleben
in den acht jahren davor hat stalins
herrschaft in der ukraine in
weißrussland und rundum leningrad zu
hungersnot und erschießungen geführt mit
vier millionen toten der diktator ist
bei vielen befürchtet doch die deutschen
truppen lassen eine weitaus größere zahl
von menschen verhungern und erschießen
und das in weniger als der hälfte der
zeit an dritte juli in seiner ersten
öffentlichen rede seit der invasion sagt
stalin genossen bürger brüder und
schwestern kämpfer unserer armee und
flotte an euch wenn die ich mich meine
freunde
stalins warme worte sind ungewöhnlich
für den diktator er beschwört seine
zuhörer weiter
wir müssen alle werktätigen zum kampf
mobilisieren um in unserem
vaterländischen krieg gegen den
deutschen faschismus unsere freiheit
unsere ehre unsere heimat unter einsatz
unseres lebens zu verteidigen
alle kräfte des volkes für die
zersplitterung des feindes vorwärts zu
unserem sieg
stalin beschwört nationalen zusammenhalt
aller volksgruppen und
gesellschaftlicher schichten gegen einen
gemeinsamen feind
am selben tag schreibt der deutsche
general oberst franz halder noch
siegessicher es ist also wohl nicht zu
viel gesagt wenn ich behaupte dass der
feldzug gegen russland innerhalb von 14
tagen gewonnen wurde am 5 juli schreibt
auch joseph goebbels in sein tagebuch
militärischer lage entwickelt sich
weiter günstig
in den ersten drei wochen rücken die
deutschen truppen 480 kilometer vor die
rote armee verzeichnet eine million
gefallene verwundete vermisste oder
gefangene dazu rund 10.000 verlorene
panzer und 4000 flugzeuge
hohe verluste aber es kommt noch viel
schlimmer
[Musik]
denn in dem norden nahmen sie wohl arg
alarms kein in der mitte und im süden
kaluga drei wichtige lebensadern die
nach moskau führten aber moskau hatten
sie noch nicht erreicht
die strategisch wichtige stadt smolensk
auf halbem weg zwischen minsk und moskau
fällt am 16 juli lief kasiewicz dient in
der roten armee
smolensk war schwer umkämpft wir waren
umzingelt ich war verwundet und hatte
mein gehör verloren unser hauptfeldwebel
war in die regiments fahne eingewickelt
einige fischer helfen uns den fluss zu
überqueren
wir schafften es ans andere ufer wo
unsere truppen lagen wir bieten ihnen
geschichtsbüchern steht schlacht um
minsk großer erfolg 300.000
kriegsgefangene schlacht um smolensk so
ähnlich 300.000 kriegsgefangene das
problem war dass das unternehmen
barbarossa nicht wie geplant umgesetzt
wurde es gelang den deutschen nicht die
rote armee und den sowjetischen
widerstand auszuschalten
hitler ist weiter zuversichtlich
am 16 juli sagt er
grundsätzlich kommt es also darauf an
den riesenhaften kuchen hand gerecht zu
zerlegen damit wir in erstens
beherrschen zweitens verwalten und
drittens ausbeuten können und er fügt
hinzu
dieser partisanenkrieg hat auch wieder
seinen vorteil er gibt uns die
möglichkeit auszurotten was sich gegen
uns stellt
der sogenannte kriegs gerichtsbarkeit
erlass barbarossa erlaubt es der ss
wehrmacht und ordnungspolizei unter dem
vorwand der partisanenbekämpfung
feindliche zivilpersonen niederzumachen
weiter unten in der befehlskette wurden
die befehle immer radikaler
an increase im sowjetischen hinterland
wurden die truppen aufgestockt um die
partisanen zu bekämpfen komba party
samens vor allem wurden immer mehr ss
bataillone in den osten entsandt dann
zunächst
am 18 juli heißt es in einem
einsatzgruppen bericht dass 3302 juden
ermordet wurden im zuge von
säuberungsaktionen an der sowjetisch
litauischen grenze
potofski ist sowjetischer soldat
zum ersten mal in unserem leben sahen
wir wie menschen getötet wurden die
deutschen töteten einfach alle der
panzergraben war voller leichen sogar
von kleinkindern
am 19 juli schreibt china gramm im
lettischen prilly in ihr tagebuch
es wurde angeordnet dass juden einen
gelben stern tragen müssen
am 27 juli schreibt sie ein juden in der
winzerstraße wurde befohlen ihre besten
kleider anzuziehen um halb vier uhr
nachmittags wurden alle juden hinter den
friedhof gejagt und erschossen es war
schrecklich wir hatten nicht damit
gerechnet dass es so endet am 8 august
noch zu ihren letzten eintrag
niemand weiß wann unsere leiden enden
werden ich habe das gefühl dass bald
noch etwas schlimmeres passiert
am 9 august wird china mit ihrer familie
und rund 1500 anderen juden aus prämie
ermordet
nur ihre 20-jährige schwester frau ja
nicht weil sich der kommandant der
einsatzgruppen noch mit ihr vergnügen
hilft
eine woche später am 16 august wird auch
sie ermordet
admiral canaris chef des militärischen
geheimdienstes hatte schon vor der
invasion gewarnt die deutschen armeen
werden auf den eisigen ebenen russlands
verbluten und wir werden nach zwei
jahren nichts mehr von ihnen wieder
finden
borussia als kurze krieg geplant aber
die wahrheit ist dass die deutschen nie
das erreicht haben was sie sich
vorgenommen hatten hamm osten saßen sie
in der falle in der east
[Musik]
am 21 juli fallen die ersten bomben of
moscow
augenzeugenberichten
um zehn uhr abends ging es los
zum ersten mal in meinem leben sah ich
einen luftangriff auf moskau
als es dunkel wurde kontrollierten wir
die fenster der gebäude jedes einzelne
musste verdunkelt werden
[Musik]
währenddessen tobt die kesselschlacht
von smolensk die erste große sowjetische
gegenoffensive wird sich über zwei
monate hinziehen und die rote armee
760.000 man kosten mit knapp einer
halben millionen toten
aber die sowjetische seite kann damit
den blitzkrieg artigen vormarsch der
deutschen bremsen
vier wochen nach beginn von unternehmen
barbarossa notiert propagandaminister
goebbels wir müssen uns bezüglich des
ost feldzugs auf eine klarere
nachrichten politik konzentrieren wir
dürfen nicht mehr so viel versprechen
wenn es sei ihm als die sowjetunion
nicht wie erwartet zusammenbrach will
hitlers blitzkrieg in sich zusammen
einen plan b hat er nicht
hitler befiehlt gegen den rat seiner
generäle panzertruppen der heeresgruppe
mitte um zu dirigieren sie sollen sich
nun auf der eroberung kiews und der
ukraine konzentrieren was den vormarsch
auf moskau abbremst
modernste anlagen von menschen tausende
von panzern und flugzeugen von oman hat
trotz alledem ist der gefürchtete
blitzkrieg energies ins schlingern
geraten und schlussendlich auf der
strecke geblieben
am 22 juli werden armeegeneral pavlov
seinen stabschef general klima vsk ich
und andere führungspersonen die bei der
vernichtenden niederlage der roten armee
in der kesselschlacht pia rostock und
minsk verantwortung getragen haben zum
tode verurteilt und fünf tage später
exekutiert
in stalins hat binären stalin hielt das
für sehr vernünftig alle sowjetischen
generäle sollten wissen dass sie
bestraft würden wenn sie seine befehle
nicht wunsch gerecht ausführten
infolge der ereignisse gibt stalin den
berüchtigten befehl nummer 270 auf
kapitulation steht für offiziere ab
jetzt die todesstrafe
soldaten die gefangen genommen werden
gelten als vaterlandsverräter
am 30 juli erlässt hitler die weisung 34
wonach die panzer gruppen zwei und drei
der heeresgruppe mitte für eine
zehntägige auffrischung von der front
abgezogen werden sollen dadurch geht
weitere zeit verloren
die planungen für das unternehmen
barbarossa sehen vor dass die wehrmacht
ein territorium erobern soll das 20 mal
so groß ist wie die in westeuropa
besetzten gebiete
und trotz aller euphorie am anfang hat
generaloberst halter nicht nur die
unendliche weite der russischen
landschaft zur kenntnis genommen sondern
er merkt auch dass
die russische gruppe kämpft mit wilder
verbissenheit und ungeheuren
menschlichen opfern
[Musik]
generaloberst halter in seinem tagebuch
auf schrieb wir sind verloren in der
sowjetischen steppe
auch bei den invasions streitkräften
steigen die verluste bis ende august
sind es über 400.000 mann aber hitler
ist zuversichtlich am sechsten september
gibt er den befehl dass die
vorbereitungen für einen angriff auf
moskau bis ende september abgeschlossen
sein müssen
während die deutschen truppen auf moskau
vorrückten evakuierten die sowjets
fabriken und große teile der
kriegswichtigen industrie nach osten
zwischen juli und oktober 1941 werden
mehr als 1500 sowjetische fabriken
demontiert und in zügen gen osten
verfrachtet auch an die 2600 industrie
und rüstungsbetriebe werden in den ural
und nach sibirien verlegt man nur in
einer planwirtschaft kann man einfach
die verlagerung einer fabrik anordnen
und züge bereitstellen die produktion
wurde zwar sichergestellt aber der preis
für das russische volk war hoch
rund 25 millionen sowjetbürger werden
nach osten umgesiedelt die meisten davon
arbeiter und arbeiterinnen mit ihren
familien sie müssen bis zu 18 stunden am
tag schuften und leben teilweise in
ausgehobenen erdlöchern
450.000 wolgadeutsche werten
zwangsumgesiedelt das ausmaß des zivilen
lights ist unvorstellbar leiten foto im
jahr 1941 begann die größte tragödie des
krieges die blockade von leningrad
am 8 september schließt sich der ring um
linien grad die deutsche luftwaffe
bombardiert die stadt massiv dabei
gezielt auch lebensmittellager kraft und
wasserwerke die belagerung wird fast 900
tage dauern mit dem ziel die bevölkerung
systematisch verhungern zu lassen sie
wird weit über eine million zivile opfer
fordern
die verzweifelten menschen essen sogar
tapetenkleister bücher schmierfett oder
kochen lieder aus den lebenden fehlt oft
die kraft die toten zu begraben
in der not geht es sogar fälle von
kannibalismus
parallel dazu schließen deutsche truppen
bei loschwitzer einen weiten ring um die
stadt kiew die sie am 26 september nach
einer kesselschlacht erobern dabei
machen sie
655.000 sowjetische gefangene
in den ersten fünf sechs monaten des
krieges starben fast zweieinhalb
millionen sowjetische kriegsgefangene
mehr als die hälfte der insgesamt rund
fünfeinhalb millionen sowjetischen
kriegsgefangenen werden bis zum ende des
krieges in deutscher gefangenschaft um
kommen von den kriegsgefangenen der
westalliierten sterben im vergleich
weniger 3,5 prozent
von 3 millionen sowjetische
kriegsgefangene starben weil die
deutschen sie nicht ernähren wollten
sie steckten sie in gefangenenlager und
ließen sie einfach verhungern
man konnte ein loch in die erde graben
und versuchen darin zu überleben sie
überließen die kriegsgefangenen ihrem
schicksal
camps gab lager mit 100.000 sowjetischen
kriegsgefangenen von denen nach zwei
monaten alle verhungert waren und wer
ist dafür verantwortlich
ein husky deutsche wehrmacht
aus einem käfer tagebuch es herrscht
totale hungersnot anscheinend wollen sie
uns qualvoll verrecken lassen es ist
wohl um praktisch alle zu erschießen
[Musik]
am 30 september beginnt das unternehmen
taifun der großangriff auf moskau mit
anfänglichen erfolgen bei der offensive
sind 78 divisionen und knapp zwei
millionen mann im einsatz
hitler wendet sich am 2 oktober
siegessicher in einer ansprache an die
soldaten an der ostfront
[Musik]
heute ist nun der beginn der letzten
großen entscheidungsschlacht dieses
jahres sie wird diesen feind vernichten
treffen
joseph goebbels und ihr zwei tage später
das wetter ist wie gesagt das
ausschlaggebende moment zur stunde ist
es noch günstig
das unternehmen teil von ist eine art
beweis für das scheitern von unternehmen
barbarossa die deutschen haben sich
kurzfristig eine neue strategie überlegt
die erst im oktober los ging als der
krieg schon längst gewonnen sein sollte
am morgen des 5 oktober meldet der
moskauer luft kommandant nicolai speed
of eine deutsche panzerkolonne 100
kilometer vor moskau stalin beordert
general schukoff umgehend von leningrad
nach moskau um die verteidigung der
hauptstadt in den griff zu bekommen
dieser stellt fest alle wege nach moskau
sind offen unsere verteidigungskräfte
sind zu schwach um das plötzliche
auftauchen feindliche panzer zu
verhindern
am 15 oktober durchbrechen deutsche
panzer die haupt verteidigungslinie der
russischen hauptstadt panik bricht aus
stahl in ordnet die evakuierung moskaus
an er selbst bleibt in der stadt da und
der stalin während der schlachten moscow
blieb betrachten einige historiker als
einen der wendepunkte des zweiten
weltkriegs
[Musik]
der anführer ist von größter bedeutung
er kann ein bild von zuversicht
erschaffen und vermitteln chemie das ist
allerdings harter arbeit
die menschen können es ihm abkaufen oder
nicht
stalins gefürchteter geheimdienstchef
lawrenz iberia gerät in panik
wie sollen wir moskau bloß verteidigen
wir haben nichts in der hand wir wurden
überwältigt sie werden uns abschießen
wie rebhühner
vassili kronen ist soldat in der roten
armee
tula war der südliche
verteidigungskosten moskau eigentlich
sollte die fünfzigste armee die stadt
verteidigen war aber bei brjansk
eingekesselt deshalb bekamen alle
einheimischen mit ausnahme der bäcker
und der arbeiter im waffenlager den
befehl tula zu verteidigen
general blumentritt beobachtet
die russischen arbeiter strömten aus den
fabriken und kämpften mit hämmern und
werkzeugen um ihre stadt zu verteidigen
kurz nach beginn des deutschen angriffs
hatte es begonnen zu regnen inzwischen
liegt vor moskau der erste schnee der
albtraum der deutschen kriegs strategen
wird war schlamm und eis verlangsamen
den ohnehin schon stockenden vormarsch
ist das wetter war umgeschlagen die
gefürchtete rasputin die zeit der
schlamm straßen hatte begonnen aber ich
würde das nicht überbewerten
oft postieren
natürlich gaben die deutschen generäle
dem russischen wetter die schuld aber
ehrlich gesagt war es kein
staatsgeheimnis dass es im dezember und
januar frost geben würde und auch dass
die russischen straßen schlecht waren
war kein geheimnis
[Musik]
die temperatur an der moskauer front
sinkt auf minus zwölf grad celsius
die angreifer die für den winter nicht
ausgerüstet sind leiden bald an
erfrierungen
gespräche über winterkleidung für die
soldaten hatte hitler sich im vorfeld
von unternehmen barbarossa verbieten
[Musik]
der nachschub stockt massiv eine
geordnete versorgung ist nicht mehr
möglich verwundete können nicht mehr
abtransportiert werden die suppe
gefriert in den schüsseln soldaten
starben an ihren erfrierungen
[Musik]
als meine story
bei minus 40 grad konnten sie nicht im
freien bleiben also vertrieben sie die
russische zivilbevölkerung aus ihren
häusern überließen sie ihrem schicksal
und zogen ein
wie viele menschen dabei ums leben
gekommen sind
general schukoff hat die zeit des
wetters genutzt um neue
verteidigungsring moskau zu ziehen und
um seine dezimierten kräfte in stellung
zu bringen
ende oktober geht er in die offensive am
30 oktober begann der erste
panzerangriff wir zerstörten 31 deutsche
panzer es war ein verlustreicher kampf
[Musik]
ivan stevanovic cognac rückt am 5
november mit carlina front nordwestlich
von moskau vor auch schon kochs
westfront greift die deutschen am tag
darauf an
[Musik]
trotz immer noch fehlender
winterkleidung starten die deutschen am
16 november einen großangriff auf moskau
am 28 november überqueren zwei panzer
gruppen bei minus 35 grad celsius den
moskau wolga kanal die stadt ist nur
noch 20 kilometer entfernt
[Musik]
zu beginn der inversion hatten die
deutschen fast anderthalb mal mehr
soldaten als die sowjets wartet die
anfang dezember 1941 moskau erreichten
hatte sich das verhältnis nahezu
umgekehrt
[Musik]
am 5 dezember schlagen die sowjets mit
einer gegenoffensive zurück nach einer
woche treten die halb erfrorenen
deutschen mit schweren verlusten den
rückzug an
am 13 dezember meldet die sechste
panzerdivision nur noch 350 schützen und
keine panzer mehr die belagerung endet
in einem debakel die dritte panzer
gruppe meldet die disziplin ist am ende
immer mehr soldaten laufen unbewaffnet
richtung westen
ein sowjetischer kommandeur der 19
schützen regale erinnert sich
im juli waren die deutschen noch
selbstbewusster starke große männer das
änderte sich dann sie waren auf einmal
erbärmlich krumm und rotzig eingewickelt
in volt tücher die sie alten frauen im
dorf weggenommen hatten
die im paket scheitern von 1941 wirkte
sich auf alle anderen operationen des
weiteren krieges aus es war eindeutig
ein wendepunkt
hitler tobt hatte er doch einen monat
zuvor schon voreilig den sieg verkünden
lassen
[Musik]
und um die lage noch komplizierter zu
machen hatte hitler am 11 dezember den
usa ohne not den krieg erklärt
[Musik]
es ist seine reaktion auf die
nachrichten aus pearl harbor am 17
dezember 1941 waren frühmorgens
japanische bomber von flugzeugträgern
aus gestartet etwa 320 kilometer
nördlich von paul haber dem stützpunkt
der us pazifikflotte auf hawaii
robert ekin war damals in pearl harbor
wir hatten an der u boot basis fest
gemacht als die japaner angriffen ich
unterhielt mich gerade mit dem first
lieutenant als er plötzlich sagte die
sind heute aber früh dran wir dachten
dabei in dem moment beide an die
luftstreitkräfte der us-armee die
sonntags morgens oft manöver abhielten
kurz darauf sahen wir einen bombenabwurf
und er sagte das ist nicht die airforce
schlagen sie alarm
und so rannten wir alle auf die gefechts
stationen
es ist 7 uhr 55 ortszeit als die erste
japanische fälle eintrifft
43 jagdflugzeuge 51 sturz kampfbomber 40
torpedo bombe und 49 normale bomber die
einen überraschungsangriff gegen die
flotten basis der in diesem krieg bisher
noch neutralen usa fliegen
wir gingen also auf unsere gefechts
stationen und feuerten auf die flugzeuge
es ging ein paar stunden lang so ich und
mein bordschütze bekamen einen halb
flugzeuge gutgeschrieben wie sie das
berechnet haben weiß ich nicht
japanische flugzeuge attackierenden
insgesamt drei angriffswellen die
flugplätze in wila carneoo de und kicker
sie feuern torpedos auf 140 vor anker
liegende kriegs und hilfsschiffe
darunter acht schlachtschiffe
die arizona wurde getroffen viele männer
wurden von der explosion erfasste und
sprangen ins wasser einige ertranken
andere verbrannten
[Musik]
aber ich war einer von denen die glück
hatten
der bomberpilot und kapitän zur see me
zu china beschreibt die szene
rauch und flammen schossen gleichzeitig
empor gemeine rote flammen wie pulver
sie erzeugt mir war sofort klar dass ein
pulver magazin explodiert war
vier von fünf männern an bord arizona
kommen ums leben
[Musik]
1177 der insgesamt 2400 drei todesopfer
an diesem tag
der überraschungsangriff ist geglückt
binnen weniger minuten sind fünf
schlachtschiffe zwei leichte kreuzer und
ein altes ziel schiff getroffen und fast
alle us flugzeuge am boden vernichtet
[Musik]
der angriff auf pearl harbor sollte der
schlüssel sein die japaner wollten so
die flotter die schlachtschiffe und die
flugzeugträger ausschalten danach
wollten sie ungehindert im britisch maja
einfallen und südostasien erobern
die japaner hätten amerika nie
angegriffen während sie nicht überzeugt
gewesen dass die briten und die
amerikaner in europa gefunden sind
um zehn uhr vormittags ist alles vorbei
der japanische plan scheint auf den
ersten blick glück zu sein und das bei
einem verlust von nur 29 flugzeugen und
fünf minuten zwei wichtige ziele haben
die angreifer jedoch verfehlt die
öltanks und die us flugzeugträger die
zum zeitpunkt des angriffs nicht im
hafen lagen
für die amerikaner ist es der tag an dem
der krieg irland endgültig erreicht
[Musik]
eine rollschuhbahn ecke sechzigste
straße und dem boulevard
moral gegen halb drei am nachmittag
tönte es aus einem der lautsprecher
wir schließen jetzt geht nach hause die
japaner haben pearl harbor angegriffen
so erfuhr ich von pearl harbor
[Musik]
an der ecke rum die es damals alle
machten dann hörten wir das palaver
angegriffen worden war aber keiner
wusste was das überhaupt war aber nie
gehört
[Musik]
der ansturm an kriegsfreiwilligen ist so
groß dass die amerikanischen
rekrutierungsbüros rund um die uhr
geöffnet bleiben
amanda palmer wurde eine art flacht ruf
wie einst dem texanischen
unabhängigkeitskrieg die parole remember
die alle mo er hat die bevölkerung
zusammengeschweißt
ich erinnere mich noch ganz genau
denn damals fand in chicago ein
footballspiel stadt
die es kamen die nachrichten und am
nächsten tag meldeten sich hunderte
junger männer freiwillig um in die usa
mehr anzutreten
aus taktischer sicht war voll habe ein
enormer erfolg für die japaner aber
politisch gesehen war der angriff eine
katastrophe denn das amerikanische volk
wollte jetzt in den krieg ziehen
am 8 dezember sagt ein mitarbeiter des
us außenministeriums
es ist der schlimmste tag in der
amerikanischen geschichte hektisch
bereiten wie den übergang vom frieden
zum krieg vor und
us präsident roosevelt hält vor dem
kongress eine historische rede
ich glaube er verdient anerkennung als
der größte präsident des zwanzigsten und
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts ich
kannte diesen moment gewachsen war
normans
dem voran
[Musik]
seine stimme bei dieser bemerkenswerten
rede die ich für eine der grössten reden
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts halter ist
wütend zutiefst wütend
der kongress stimmt mit 470 zu einer
stimme für den krieg janet ranken die
pazifistische kongressabgeordnete aus
montana äußert bedingt als frau kann ich
nicht in den krieg ziehen und ich
weigere mich irgendjemand anderen
hinzuschicken
[Musik]
zum zeitpunkt der abstimmung ist die us
armee kaum 100.000 mann stark bis zur
japanischen kapitulation an bord der uss
missouri am 2 september 1945 werden die
vereinigten staaten fast 15 millionen
soldaten mobilisieren
ein krieg unvorstellbaren ausmaßes nimmt
weiter seinen lauf